welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and hoax mystery alternate sea
from Avengers infinity war has finally
been revealed to us thanks to a big dump
of bonus footage from the infinity Saga
that damn jungle jog that was excluded
from the infinity war Final Cut has
haunted me ever since was it just shot
and rendered for the promo no no we now
have the alternate scene showing Bruce
banners transformation into smart Hulk
in the final act of infinity war not
in-game with Hulk burst and out of that
hole Buster armor as the toys promised
us he would we got to break this down
not just to cover well-worn territory
from the Infinity Saga that we've
already made a bunch of videos about
because I think this ultimate sequence
gave us a big clue for Hulk's future
film appearances and how Marvel could
explain she-hulk
Jennifer Walters in the upcoming Disney
series more than won't any case I
predict anything - right in real life
okay
we all remember Hulk's role in the
Battle of Lokhande at the end of
infinity war remember when he was a
no-show banner suited up in the
Hulkbuster armor and faced off against
cull obsidian in a pond
oh wow begging hope to a murder you like
making your entrance the last anyway
banner managed to slide that armored
gauntlet piece onto Cole's
arm and sent him team rocket blasting up
again and then he essentially punted his
inner conflict with Hulk to the sequel
look who got Aleph to figure out pal and
when we catch up with banner an in-game
he has already transformed into smart
Hulk giving us very little of an
explanation for years I've been treating
the hall quickie some kind of disease
something to get rid of but then I start
looking at him as the cure 18 months in
a gamma lab I put the brains and the
Brawn together and now they give me best
of both worlds yeah but like 18 months
doing what in the gamma lab Bruce
pictures off but then gene back with
some soon a start whatever happened the
filmmakers did say that they originally
planned to reveal smart Hulk in the
final act of infinity war they decided
to move it to endgame because the fusion
of banner and Hulk would feel like too
much of a victory when Infinity Ward
needed to feel like a defeat
but now we get to see that alternate
version the sequence was never finished
so the most we have is this hilarious
mix of unrendered VFX and shots of Mark
Ruffalo performing the part in a motion
capture studio so potato call obsidian
and potato Hulkbuster banners slug it
out then banner begins his inner
dialogue big guy I know I have it some
issues here but if you're gonna appear
at any moment now it'd be a hell of a
good time
so what you like to fight I don't hate
you you're more than an Avenger than I
am I love you though you don't just want
to leave let's leave we'll leave it let
me hear it yes yes okay I got I got an
idea so then banner draws Cole back and
then he blocks his blow
and then the animation shows our big
green [ __ ] bursting out of the armor
to punch cold city and then he picks up
the boot of the shattered Hulkbuster
armor claps it on his foot and sends
team rocket blasting off again again and
then I love this an incredulous smart
Hulk looks down at his reflection his
potato Shrek hands clipping through his
knees and then reaches up to his face
marveling at this fusion between his
banner and Hulk's elves oh and then this
leads to another alternate sequence with
Natasha in Sam they run into big green
[ __ ] assuming he's in his old rage
mode and then Natasha goes into her calm
down ritual that she had an age of
Ultron
who worked it up the fact that say it's
gone from worst case scenario to I don't
know if it's best case but at least it
feels very very manageable yeah Suns
getting real low and smart Hulk doesn't
give up while I was perfectly satisfied
with the way Smart Hulk was revealed an
in-game it's still valuable to see this
alternate version because it does give
us a real explanation for how banner and
Hulk worked it out rather than you know
some big mumbling about 18 months in a
gamma lab here we see Banner and Hulk
engage in a real argument they're forced
to listen to each other to settle their
differences and to co-exist just as the
comics have often depicted these beauty
and identities and we see how this
evolution frees him from his attachment
to Natasha really his handler from age
of Ultron and it gives Banner a new
inner partnership something we could
kind of see again in future MCU
installments look sometimes I wish I
could make peace with my inner rage
monster like you know on the days when I
don't get enough sleep the night before
or I'm overtired during the work day
your ability starts to build up inside
me and I'm always angry
lose control lashing out against the
people I care about it's mostly just
complaining to our editor that our big
red arrows aren't big red enough one way
that I've been able to keep control over
my energy level throughout the day is
with bang energy and thanks to bang for
sponsoring in this video every can of
bang is Hulk size 16 ounces that's right
no wimpy Bruce Banner 12 ounce cans here
it contains 300 milligrams of caffeine
it's sugar-free and has zero calories
yet it tastes great
one of those great flavors is sour heads
it's kind of like a really good sour
candy but without like an overpowering
sweet flavor it's just kind of subtle
and gives you a bit of a tartness and
keeps you from becoming a green and hold
like really a sip of this baby launches
a discussion in my brain I love you
energy Eric I love your two externally
introverted Eric live and let live what
about a lot lard and bang you get this
it's a smart whole fusion of brains and
well not exactly brawn but like shouting
and gesticulation check out bang on
Instagram you can get 20% off your order
at Bank - energy calm when you use the
code new rock stars twenty five there
you can get a variety 12-pack with a
dozen of their flavors flavors like a
pina colada
a copy okay the upper they cake - India
sour heads
thanks again - bang energy for
sponsoring this video get 20% off at
bang energy com using the code new rock
stars 25 and hey follow the inventor of
bang on instagram at bang energy dot CEO
but back to what this alternate hulk
scene could tell us about his future now
this kind of inner dialogue between
identities is fascinating to watch and
it would be a shame if it's the last
time we see this kind of thing in the
MCU now Mark Ruffalo has said that he
doesn't think a standalone MCU Hulk film
will ever happen however Ruffalo does
still have to Marvel films left on his
Marvel contract meaning we could still
see him as part of an ensemble in an
upcoming Avengers team-up movie or as a
co-star in another MCU film as he wasn't
thor ragnarok like think about it thor
xi under dr. strange to the multiverse
of madness guardians of the galaxy vol 3
all of these could be great ensemble
films that would fit right into we also
know Marvel made a deal with Sony for
one more team-up film that's gonna
feature Tom Holland is Spider Man beyond
spider-man 3 in 2021
if we assume as I have before that that
team-up could be the introduction of
Reed Richards and the Fantastic Four
perhaps these new brainiacs will reveal
to banner an opportunity to reverse his
gamma radiation and restore his old self
which could tempt this man with the
choice to sever his current partnership
with his big green [ __ ] now we also
know that as she-hulk series is in the
works at Disney Plus with Bruce banners
cousin Jennifer Walters who pretty
quickly reached a level of stasis with
her Hulk identity so that she lives her
life and practices law in herb Smart
Hulk form perhaps she-hulk will open
with a similar inner dialogue but
Jennifer and her Hulk identity bite
that stage of interviewing that banner
and Hulk went through and they realized
right off the bat that they can go
further if they work together so this
way she's always angry but she's also
always in control
whatever that series ends up being I
hope the Marvel team leans into this
alternate version of Hulk's evolution
that they almost went with an infinity
war and brings us in on that dialogue so
that the fusion that we see on the
outside is something that we're
constantly impressed by rather than
something we take for granted
after a quick non explanation involving
18 months in a gamma lab if you want to
hear more of my unfiltered opinions
about Marvel films and thoughts on
things like Jane join us on Dischord
that's really where the real
conversations happen in here at new
rockstars our gut reactions to trailers
discussions about other stuff that we're
watching and edging to theories I'm too
embarrassed to share here to join us on
desk or become a patron a day at
patreon.com slash new rock stars so
would you have preferred banner becomes
smart Hulk in infinity war comment down
below with your thoughts follow me at EA
vas follow new rockstars those social
media subscribe to new rockstars on
YouTube for more of our Marvel theories
thanks for watching
[Music]